this is a chart from the new york times
that shows us how per capita gdp has
trended on an inflation-adjusted basis
since 1947. so you can really think
about this as the post-world war ii era
world war ii of course ended in 1945.
it's always good to read the fine print
to make sure we understand what this is
telling us and what it's not telling us
as i mentioned it is adjusted for
inflation it also says that the incomes
given here are post-tax and include
government benefits so if someone's
getting a government benefit of a
certain value per year that would be
included in their income here and if
someone is saying making a hundred
thousand but paying 35 000 in taxes then
the income is post tax it would be the
hundred thousand minus the 35 000 or 65
000. and there are several interesting
things here this is showing us growth
since 1947 so it's not that folks in
1947 that we had a zero per capita gdp
or that there was zero income it's just
obviously in 1947 you haven't had any
growth since 1947 and then as you move
forward in time over roughly the next 30
years you get to about 1980 it looks
like you've had about a hundred percent
growth now whenever i think in terms of
percentage growth hundred percent growth
two hundred percent growth i always like
to do a little bit of a reality check of
how would that compare to where i
started i like to view the zero percent
growth as 100 percent of 1947 i'll make
another axis here on the right to
supplement what's already there so this
would be 100
of
1947 then if i grow 100 from that that's
the same thing as doubling so 200
percent
of
1947. this right over here if i grow by
200 that means i am at
300 percent
of
1947
and then if i've grown by 300
that means i am at 400 percent
of
1947. so one way to think about it is
over the course of the 30 years or 33
years from 1947 to 1980 it looks like
inflation adjusted per capita gdp has
essentially doubled it has grown by 100
percent and it also looks like in this
yellow line where they're telling us the
average income for the bottom 90 percent
so bottom 90 that's essentially everyone
but the top 10 percent it looks like
it's roughly tracked per capita gdp in
fact it looks like it might have been a
little bit ahead of that over some of
those years so if you go from 1947 to
1980 per capita gdp has roughly doubled
and average incomes for that bottom 90
percent has roughly doubled
now something interesting or at least
this graph is highlighting something
that might be interesting over the next
40-year period from 1980 to roughly
today which is per capita gdp has
continued to trend upward at a seemingly
similar rate
but the income the average income for
the bottom 90 percent does not seem to
keep pace with that in other videos we
looked at 1980 to now and we saw this
trend but we didn't have the historical
data from 1947 to 1980 to see that you
don't always see this in order for that
to happen that means that the top 10
percent must be growing faster i'm just
making up some curve like that it must
be going at a faster rate and even this
might be surprising some of you you
might say all right the bottom 90 is not
growing as fast as the average across
the country but by this measure it looks
like on an inflation-adjusted after-tax
basis the bottom 90 percent is at 300
percent of 1947 now give or take and it
was at 200 percent of 1947 in 1980 give
or take which means that the standard of
living since 1980 should have improved
by about 50 percent for this bottom 90
group and i know for a lot of y'all who
have been around since 1980 or who know
about 1980 says well maybe that's the
case most of us definitely have better
computing power now we have nicer large
screen flat tvs we have cheaper
manufactured goods but other things feel
harder for a lot of folks than 1980
things like buying a house or health
care or college tuition and that goes to
something that we will probably dig into
more in other videos and that's how
inflation is measured i'm not going to
go into detail other parts on khan
academy we talk about how inflation is
measured in the consumer price index
whenever you look at any statistics it's
always important to think about how are
they calculated and what are the
underlying assumptions because inflation
is trying to capture how much can you
buy with a certain amount of money but
that calculation is dependent on what
you think people are buying or how you
measure the cost of it so we'll talk
about that in future videos but the big
takeaway here is is that the historic
trend is at the bottom 90 percent has
roughly grown with per capita gdp but it
seems like there's something about the
last 40 years whether it's tax policy
monetary policy demographic changes
technology globalization education and
maybe all of the above that has led to a
change in the trend